[Musik]
fast jeden abend präsentiert wladimir
solowjow einer von putins prominentesten
scharfmachern im staats-tv seine große
propaganda show da wird zum beispiel
deutschland offen mit krieg gedroht
westliche politiker werden beschimpft
und an den pranger gestellt in dieser
sendung ist eu kommissionspräsident in
ursula von der leyen dran von der leyen
spricht über europäische werte und dass
die ukraine den krieg gewinnen soll dann
kommt solovyov mit einem nazi-vergleich
da fehlt nur noch ein sieg heil und die
hacken zusammenschlagen so der moderator
er sagt ursula begreifst du welchen
unsinn du redest und er wendet sich an
deutschland zuständig ihr seid es
gewohnt dass dem deutschen reich der
kleine bruder dient das ukrainische
reich wanderer ist ein treuer nachahmer
des führers der deutschen nationalelf
hitler
was macht das mit den russinnen und
russen wenn den ganzen tag im fernsehen
nur propaganda und hetze laufen dieser
herr prophezeit unserem russischen
mitarbeiter eine schwierige zukunft wenn
er so weitermacht dann deutschen
fernsehen offene drohung aber nicht alle
folgen dieser propaganda
alles krasse lügen ich weiß nicht ob er
das selbst glaubt es ist schwer so levy
ob überhaupt einen journalisten zu
nennen
meiner erfahrung nach informieren sich
die leute eher über youtube und
telegramm und die ältere generation
kupfer
den ganzen tag flimmern die immer
gleichen botschaften über die
staatskapelle der westen sei verkommen
mit seinen unfähigen politikern und fake
medien das liberale gesellschaftsmodell
in europa und den usa sei gescheitert
die frierenden deutschen die sich mit
den sanktionen vor allem selbst schaden
putins informations truppen sind die
hauptstütze des regimes wichtiger als
die strukturen der rechtsschutz und
sicherheitsorgane die propaganda
gewährleistet die loyalität der
bevölkerung sie sichert das hinterland
ab das ist das wichtigste kritik wird
unterdrückt wer das russische militär
den augen des kremls öffentlich
diskreditiert kann im gefängnis landen
am freitag erst wurde der moskauer
lokalpolitiker alexej gori noch zu
sieben jahren haft verurteilt weil er
die russische militär operation in einer
ratssitzung als krieg bezeichnet braucht
ihr diesen krieg noch fragt er an
tuberkulose erkrankte chorin auf diesem
zettel noch bei seiner verurteilung
applaus seiner familie und anhänger er
will nichts zurücknehmen und der 60
jährige fügt noch hinzu sie haben mir
den frühling genommen sie haben mir den
sommer genommen und jetzt haben sie mir
sieben jahre meines lebens genommen